Marc Chagall's contemporaries banished God from their works.
But for him, painting was inconceivable without transcendence.
As he once said, "The artist is a messenger of God."
His life is a reflection of much of the 20th century's biggest stories.
A Russian Jew, he witnessed World War I and the Russian Revolution.
He sought refuge in the United States after Nazi Germany's rise.
Despite all the suffering, his painting never lost color.
He said that it was because color is how he expressed his emotions.
A fascination with this artistic giant...
...has brought visitors from around the world to his exhibit.
The message is extremely love.
Love is the most important thing of life.
And don't use too much your heads but your hearts.
That's Chagall.
The Love and Life exhibition will be in Rome until July 26th, 2016.
It traces the life of the painter through what Chagall called the engine of life: love.
If anything characterizes him, it is his famous scenes of lovers,...
...all inspired by his wife Bella.
The artist said in his autobiography that his country was his soul.
He could travel without a passport whenever he wanted.
Now, for a few weeks in Rome,...
...one can join this unique artist for a short journey without carrying documents.